hi there and welcome to another episode
of study with me today I'm going to be
talking about special relativity an area
and physics that I have studied somewhat
before but I've kind of forgotten a few
things and I'm definitely a bit rusty so
I'm going to just work through some
concepts and special relativity mostly
an intro to space-time diagrams and some
of the cool results that you can start
to use those diagrams to discover so
whether you have studied this topic
yourself before and want a bit of a
refresher or you want to learn some of
these topics from the ground up I hope
that listening along to me talking about
some special relativity will be
enjoyable and to your benefit so like I
said I've studied special relativity
before and there are a few key things I
do definitely remember and I think I'm
going to need to know that you'll need
to know to progress a little bit here
and I've written them up on the
blackboard so let's have a look at some
of our fundamental concepts that I know
and hopefully use these to build a bit
of a base to go on and get a better
understanding of space-time diagrams now
I remember those being a very cool
aspect of special relativity but I'm
sort of hazy on the details of how they
work there is some words I remember like
space like and time like but I can't
quite remember what those mean so let's
work up to that
now the first really important point is
that an observer and someone or
something that makes physical
measurements so whenever we refer to an
observer that's what we're talking about
second of all your position in your
reference frame is always zero so we're
going to talk a bit about reference
frames here and our observers are going
to exist inside reference frames just
know that the observer will always think
that they are staying still that their
position is zero and that everything
else is moving around them special
relativity is often credited as one of
iron Stein's you know inventions and we
have some of iron Stein's important
postulates here we've got
- and these really govern what's going
on in special relativity so one the laws
of physics are the same in all inertial
reference frames so an inertial
reference frame is one where I guess
Newtonian physics applies it's a
reference frame that is either staying
still or is moving at a constant speed
really we're just not including
accelerating reference frames and I
think this inertial reference frames is
what makes special relativity special as
opposed to general relativity which can
deal with acceleration then likewise
gravity so that's the first one that the
laws of physics will be the same and -
the speed of light in free space is the
same and all inertial reference frames
as well okay so that speed of light is a
constant when we're talking about
inertial reference frames so I think
that's all of the important details that
we're going to need to know hopefully
some of them might be a bit of a
refresher to you and let's go on and use
them to understand a few more concepts
I'm going to be working through the
special relativity course on brilliant
org so if you want to use the same
course to follow along you can sign up
for free at brilliant org slash Tippy's
and the first 200 of you that want to do
that can get 20% off an annual premium
subscription okay so our first picture
here is that we have a girl moving
forwards on a raft we have a guy in a
balloon moving forwards and we have a
goal a moving force as well as Siegel
okay so we've got three different
reference frames here in the skills
reference frame she thinks that she's
not moving that the balloon is moving
away from her and that the goal is
moving away from here as well so
space-time diagrams they can be used for
something as simple as this problem that
we're looking at here even though no one
is moving close to the speed of light
and this is really just classical
mechanics here for this diagram here we
have time on the y axis and X down on
the
which is position so this blue line that
is putted here is the path of the
seagull the point that it intercepts is
the initial position when you first
started to observe it this is all for
the reference frame of the girl on the
raft and this diagram here is from the
reference frame of the guy who was on
the balloon who was moving forwards at
his own speed this is how he perceives
the girl so we've still got time and
instead of X we just have X dash to be a
new reference frame it's still the
position though so this is Galilean
relativity as opposed to a a special
relativity because no one's really
moving at a very high speed and
observers agree on the time that all
events take place so the axis on the
space-time diagram and this new frame is
still just labeled T instead of T -
because they're not going to agree on
the exact position of the bird relative
to them but they will agree on the time
so we do have a question here relating
to this diagram if we are on the raft
and this is from the point of view of
the guy on the balloon who's moving away
from us which is moving faster the guy
on the balloon or the seagull
now we can't actually tell the answer
just from looking at this diagram here
even though it doesn't seem like we've
got much information and the answer is
that the goal is moving away faster and
the reason that this is true is because
this was from the point of view of the
guy in the balloon and the position of
the goal was moving away from him so if
he's moving relative to the girl on the
raft and for him the gull was moving
away from him then to the girl on the
raft the bird is moving away even faster
than the guy on the balloonist lines
that are drawn on space-time diagrams
are referred to as world lines and they
do encode quite a lot of information
about an object that is moving so we can
actually get the speed that an object is
moving from its world line slope of a
line is the change in the rise over the
change in the runs
that's DT over DX change in time of a
change in position in this case that
turns out to be one over the speed of
the goal so the world line is inversely
proportional to the velocity or the
relative velocity so that means the
steeper the world line the lower the
velocity and the less steep the world
line the higher their velocity now we're
going to extend our examples to
something that's referred to and
brilliant as relativistic laser tag so
in this game we're going to have two
people ELISA and Bev and they're
practicing for a laser tag tournament
and they win by hitting the target on
the other team with simultaneous laser
bolts so they both need to hit this
target at the same time they set up a
target that's halfway between them and
they are at rest relative to each other
the target is also at rest in their
reference frame their goal is to
coordinate their firing so that their
lasers had the target simultaneously
they have a countdown and then at T
equals zero they both pull the trigger
do they see their laser bolts hitting
the target at the same time well I'm
going to say yes because I've got no
reason to believe otherwise okay so they
have another friend called crater who
helps them move the targets around
during practice and he's always keeping
an eye out to help them improve their
game he's usually on the move and his
shuttle runs at only one speed which is
out of control so that sounds like he is
moving pretty fast he observes the
practice from a different reference
frame so he will possibly have a
different take on events so long as he
doesn't turn or otherwise accelerate his
frame of reference is an inertial frame
and his observations are governed by
einstein's postulates okay so that means
the speed of light would be the same and
so will the laws of physics suppose
crater is heading toward Alyssa with a
speed V relative to her at the instant
she fires her laser with what speed does
the laser bolt approach crater in his
his frame okay so if instead of talking
about a laser bolt we'd been talking
about the seagull from before I would
incline to be give one of these other
ounces that the speed would take into
account craters relative speed towards
the object towards the seagull but
because we know and sines postulates
here and there directly telling us to
use them the speed of light and all
inertial reference frames should be the
same okay so that seems good I'll keep
going
so now crater is during a spacetime
diagram as he passes the two girls at
speed V and craters inertial frame it's
actually the two girls who are moving
with speed V and to him he's staying
still
so he's drawn their world lines and blue
here we've got Alyssa and Bev crater
calls the time that Alyssa fires T
equals zero so that's this point here in
his frame of reference at this moment
crater measures the target at a distance
x over two from him and Alice's position
so this here is the target which is
halfway between the two girls in red
here is Alyssa's laser shot so we're
being asked at what time and craters
frame does Alyssa's bolt hit the target
so what is this ta right here so
something else you may want to remember
from physics as a relationship between
speed distance and time well time is
distance divided by speed so what
distance has the shot traveled it's x
over two and we'll divide that by the
speed it was going now it's sort of my
intuition to want to do x over two
divided by C which would be x over two
see that is none of the options I can't
see any reason why it'd be C squared or
why would we have this squared here so
I'm going to pick a and I think just
formation looking at the answers I
realize where this C minus V is coming
from so
whilst they both measure the bolt to be
moving at speed see according to crater
the target is moving with speed V as the
bolt is catching up to it so that's why
it's not just see on the bottom but it's
C minus V so now Bev is going to take a
shot
according to crater does bends and laser
bolt take more time this time or the
same amount of time to reach the target
compared to Alyssa looking at this
diagram it looks like that as the shot
is going towards the target the target
is getting closer to Bev so for that
reason I'm going to say it should take
beams beam less time okay so that one's
getting a bit trickier but I think we're
doing all right
so crater reports to Alyssa and B of
that you aren't firing and sync so even
though he sees the bolts at the target
at the same time he thinks there's a
time difference between when Alyssa and
bhuvah firing because he thinks that
Bebe's beam takes a less time to get to
the target so in order for the bolts to
hit the targets simultaneously in
craters reference frame how long after
Alyssa fires does Bev need to pull the
trigger okay so you want to find this
distance here which is essentially the
change in time that crater thinks has
happening between the time when the
girls pull the triggers so again time is
distance divided by speed we know from
back here that this is the time for
Alyssa's beam and this would differ with
a plus sign down here on the bottom for
Bibbs time so we really want to do this
- the same friction except with a plus
sign between the C and the V might be
slightly tricky algebra so I'm going to
take a stab at it I guess I guess this
one this it's the first one this is that
hold but you need to do so this is
Alyssa's time this is Bev's time you
want to subtract them which means you
need to convert them to having the same
denominator as their fractions and then
do the algebra
from there but I think we understand
sort of what's going on here it's the
time that crater 4 seems there to be
between the two girls firing so Alyssa
gets on the comlink and says crater what
are you talking about we're firing it
exactly at the same time and of course
that's what it looks like from her
reference frame so puzzled crater does
an experiment he performs a u-turn in a
shuttle and heads back towards Bev now
according to crater who shot will
require less time to hit the target so
now he's just going the other way so I
guess it would make sense that things
are reversed and now it would seem like
Alyssa's shot takes less time yeah so
okay this sort of seeming a bit strange
and this is relating to the strangeness
of simultaneity and special relativity
so if light propagates at the same speed
for all inertial observers as Einstein
said we arrive quickly at some pretty
bizarre conclusions
according to crater who was moving
relative to the target beer vanilla
sapphire at different times yet their
bolts arrived simultaneous perhaps even
stranger the person who fires first
switches of crater changes as direction
so especially at the time when Einstein
came up with this the idea that
observers experience events and
different order depending on which
direction they're moving seems quite
absurd but you know these calculations
of Einstein's theory of special
relativity have actually been tested and
repeated and all of it seems to stack up
so these things are true but there are
some very counterintuitive aspects to
learning about special relativity so
what we've moved on to here is the topic
of causality so you know in everyday
life if a window was opened which made
it possible for a baseball to fly into
the room which knocked a lamp off the
table and smashed it then a causal
relationship was established the
chronology of these events or the order
in which they happened must be absolute
mustn't it so what does it mean for a
causality in these
realm of special relativity where we've
said you know the order of events
depends on who you are and where you're
moving so we ask are there any sequences
of events whose order is absolute and
we're going to consider events a and B
shown on this space-time diagram so do
note that the white line here at 45
degrees through the diagram represents
the world line of a light beam so this
is the speed of light represented and
remember it's velocity is inversely
proportional to the slope so anything
down here the slope would mean it
travels faster than the speed of light
and anything up here less than the speed
of light so what relationship between a
and B guarantees that we can find two
observers who disagree on their order so
if we take a look at this the slope
connecting a and B is a lower gradient
than the speed of light which would mean
it's faster but as this answer here that
the slope is less than light what it
means for a and B is that they have
quite a curious relationship they have
no set watering and time depending on
the reference frame we're in it can be
either that a happens before B a happens
after B or they occur at the same time
so what about space is there a frame
where these two events occur at the same
position I'm gonna go with no here and
that's correct so let's see why there is
a fundamental separation between the
events a and B and that a beam of light
cannot be sent between the two so their
separation and space is greater than the
distance that light can travel and the
time that separates them so the
separation is independent of the
reference frame so no matter how we tilt
the axis or what speed reference frame
is going out relative to them there is
no frame that exists where a and B could
appear at the same position in space for
this reason events like this our
called space like separated and on the
other hand we have up here time like
separated which is just sort of by
symmetry where we can always find a
reference frame in which they have the
same position but they will never have
the same time it gets kind of cool when
we sort of make that diagram look 3d I
guess by instead of just having one line
world line representing a light beam we
spin that around to be an entire light
cone so here it is still a spacetime
diagram of you know time and space but
we really clearly see the difference
between space like separated events and
time like separated events so any events
that exist within the light cone would
be time like separated and you know if
an event happens down here the speed of
light propagates outwards in all
directions in this cone and anything in
the future that's what in the cone I
guess can interact with that beam of
light it means that anything in that
cone essentially is the future and
anything in an inverse cone as the past
and we can't have any knowledge or
interaction with something outside of
how light cone the light cone is all the
possible events that can have a physical
effect on us so we're asked a question
here which of the traditions
maybe or see on this space-time diagram
is physical so let's have a look at them
festival see this event here or this
trajectory would require going faster
than the speed of light because you know
it's it's gradient is down here with a
slope less than that of light so we're
going to rule out C as being not
physical and B both stay within the
light cone so they could seem very
physical but if you look at it a
actually has a gradient in here which is
less steep than that of light so it too
is requiring faster than light travel to
reach its destination
the only really viable one here is B so
I'm going to leave this episode here I
hope that you've learned a couple of
things about space-time diagrams and you
know causality your simultaneous events
really I hope that this is just an
inspiration for you to want to learn a
bit more of these ideas yourself and
explore more official relativity because
it is such a big topic and to teach you
all or even a big chunk of it in a
single video is really difficult but
thank you very much for watching and
I'll see you next time
you